I've been admiring those freaks of yours
for quite some time well life is about
to get even weirder because we now know
when and where season two of Doom Patrol
will be coming so we're gonna break down
everything we know about the second
season right now on the ketchups
after a first season that came in
certified fresh' at 96% on the tomato
meter fans and critics wanted more from
this show that lives on the DC Universe
streaming service check out our episode
on that and other niche services if you
haven't already thankfully a year and a
half after second season was greenlit it
was announced that Doom Patrol a show
about a misfit group of superheroes will
come our way June 25th on both DC
Universe and the new streaming service
HBO max double-whammy
and on top of that season 1 will also be
available on HBO max when the service
launches on May 27 so you'll be able to
catch up on all the weirdness by the end
of the month you can now in season one
we saw robot Man Elastigirl negative man
crazy gene and cyborg dealing with their
own personal baggage while also trying
to rescue their mentor the chief Niles
Caulder for pretty much the dopest
villain ever mr. nobody brilliant play
by Alan Judith I haven't been mr. Morton
since I know okay fYI this is a spoiler
alert when we left this group of the
world's strangest heroes following the
defeat of mr. nobody in Ezekiel the
cockroach most of them were tiny sized
and still facing their own demons along
with the bombshell of betrayal that was
dropped by the chief and while we're not
entirely sure they even want to stick
together they have to find a way to
embrace and protect the newest member of
the family that they rescued which is
Niles his daughter Dorothy spinner who
will be played by Abigail Shapiro
now while Dorothy's powers remain a bit
of a mystery if she's anything like her
comic book character a young psychic who
had the power to turn her imaginary
friends into real people so cool
perdition could open up some very
interesting story opportunities for
season 2 including bringing on the
threat of the end of the world
[Music]
this is what the world looks like when
we try to live in it
we may also see the show jump ahead a
little in time to allow Dorothy to be a
little bit older and more mature thus
allowing her powers to be fully realized
so stay tuned
another point to keep an eye out for in
season two is the fate of mr. nobody and
a beard hunter apparently they survived
the nuclear explosion because as the
finale ends we see an image of the two
villains on the blank canvas that had
been used to contain Danny of the street
and it's worth noting that after meeting
a similar fate in the comics mr. nobody
escaped from his prison and went on to
run for president of the United States
something that could definitely add a
new fun way for Alan Tudyk to shine in
the role moving forward you're all at my
mercy all right friends it's time for us
to kick it over to you now are you
excited for season 2 of Doom Patrol
enough to get a subscription to HBO max
maybe and what are you expecting to see
in season 2 let us know our thoughts and
feelings in the comment section and for
more streaming news or binge guides
check out Rotten Tomatoes calm also do
not forget to join our finger on
Facebook like RJ here who actually has a
special message for you guys hey I'm RJ
and I'm from the Philippines stay safe
stay fresh and if you don't want to miss
out on any future episodes of the show
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always thank
you guys for watching to catch up we
love you so much and we hope to see you
in the next video bye
[Music]
you